in the wake of donald trump's completely
depraved and deplorable maskless stunt
at the white house monday evening after
leaving the hospital
with coronavirus jack holmes wrote a
very good piece in esquire
about really what is the urgent decline
of america
and the pressing imperative to remove
donald trump
and he really hits many important points
that i want to talk about jack writes in
his piece quote
we have been heading down this road to
ruin for some time now but the
end stages are somehow uglier
and more empty than seemed possible and
he adds that quote
if you were looking for a portrait of an
american empire in decline
it arrived monday evening when donald j
trump
in the thick of about with covet 19
checked himself out of the hospital at
walter reed national military medical
center
and was flown back to the white house on
marine one going on to say that quote
he climbed the curved staircase reached
the balcony
and removed his mask in what appeared to
be a gesture of defiance
of what the media the deep state
scientists
reality itself it was not immediately
clear
but that trademark pout was unmistakable
this was authoritarian chic the
president was looking at something
very strongly that's for sure though it
will not be an
ounce of humility or growth as a human
being
after he was struck by the very disease
he so long downplayed and ignored
at the cost of so many american lives
and this article which i would encourage
you to read
outlines the mockery that donald trump
has made of personal responsibility
and how actions have consequences the
excesses of empire the delusions of
grandeur but i'd go even further donald
trump
has completely undermined the executive
branch of the united states
he's undermined the justice department
he's undermined science and education
and the people of america and common
sense
he's undermined and and really
eliminated
the status of the united states as a
worthy participant in the experiment
of humans on planet earth that is the
degree to which this man has debased
homo sapiens on this planet
we are now a joke and we are pitied by
the world now
it's not you know for a while they were
merely laughing
when i now hear from our friends in
other countries
they are scared for for us and for
themselves
and they pity us and we are the danger
corrupt leaders the world over
are enjoying the catastrophe that is the
world under trump
while our historical allies in western
democracies
are horrified and they're desperate for
a change for a return
to normalcy and part of the problem part
of this rapid decline
has to be accounted for in the more than
60 million who voted for trump in 2016
and the likely more than 60 million that
will vote for him
again this november so we often talk
about
trump the people under trump the people
who work for trump the kaylee mcinannies
and the sean spicers they deserve to
never work again
because of what they've participated in
but what about the 60 million
trumpists that are part of this
debasement what happened
to supposed christian values on the
republican side i guess it was just bs
they were blowing smoke
can't republicans see a man who is lying
to them
all the time for his own purposes as not
in line with what they claim to be about
do they see it and not care is there
that much cognitive dissonance taking
place consider how absurd the hospital
stunt was
notice that trump came home from the
hospital
with the orange face after having the
white face for a few days
while at the hospital because he wasn't
getting the makeup contagious
with covid trump had his makeup done by
someone at the hospital
the micro is pathetic and the macro is
simply dystopian
how much more of this can we take
unfortunately the right seems
more than willing to take much more of
it i spotted this comment on a
right-wing
enclave on the internet reacting to the
trump photo op propaganda video when he
came back from the hospital they said
quote
people on the left are going to lose
their minds this is going to be so fun
to watch
that is emblematic of what we are
fighting right now it's not about
conservative values if you actually look
you don't have to agree with them but if
you just find sort of like a normal
traditional conservative
they have essentially nothing in common
with donald trump
this isn't about economic policy this
isn't about social policy
it's about angering the left as they
said the left is going to lose their
minds
over trump flying back from walter reed
in a helicopter
they want to own the libs trigger the
left as they like to say
so democrats must win in a landslide
this november if we are to avoid
a chance of another four years of this
and
probably democrats need to win in a
landslide on i hate to say this
but to avoid the violence i fear we will
see
if it's close and trump says it was
rigged and i really won
we need a landslide to avoid the
violence as well
the window of opportunity is closing
here we are now
just what is it 27 days to go as
of today barely to 26 and a half days
the window is closing and we have a real
opportunity here and fortunately joe
biden is actually
starting to help his own cause and i
want to talk about that next
today one of our sponsors is surf shark
which is a premium vpn service they're
giving my audience
83 off a two-year plan plus three extra
months for free
coming out in total to about two bucks a
month
it's 2020. if you're not already using a
vpn
now is the time to start vpns hide your
ip address online
protects you from government
surveillance big tech companies can't
track you online
and internet service providers won't be
able to log
and sell your internet history surfshark
is the vpn i trust because they don't
monitor or log
your internet activity like many other
vpns do it encrypts your data you can
install it on unlimited devices
it can block ads protect you from
malware and phishing
and it even lets you stream tv shows and
movies
that are only available in other
countries surf shark is giving my
audience
83 off a two-year plan plus
three extra month free so that comes out
to just about two dollars a month which
is
almost nothing relative to the peace of
mind you will have while browsing online
just go to surfshark.deals
pacman i've put the link underneath this
video and make sure to use the coupon
code pacman